we have dr farmine lagann from the
southern nevada health district
we have trustee irene cepeda from the
clark county school district board of
trustees and we have superintendent jara
so again now just i know i've told you
all this before but again we're
reiterating no video of the clinic
um we do have consent forms if you do
find somebody who is willing to speak
with you
on camera or for your
newspapers so we're going to get started
if you want guys want to come up
so i'm trying to hold this just
that's okay that's okay that's okay i
got it
okay um good afternoon and thank you for
being here with us
today we we want to share with you
what we are doing or planning to do in
the near future
actually what we are planning to do
is uh one more example of the strong
partnership that we have with craig
county school district
we we have been working with the with
clark county school district for you
know
in multiple issues and especially during
the pandemic we have
a very strong and close collaboration
with
the school system and and this is just
an example of that
what we are planning to do starting
this week is to to to offer
a vaccination to the community at a
school sites there
there will be a multiple vaccination
sites
across the county at school locations
those fascination sites will be offering
a
kobe vaccine to
individuals who are 12 years old and
over
and in this case is very important
because
that illegal population now
includes children
12 years and over which is which who are
also as you know
a part of the the school community
so a mostly a student between
middle school and high school
also those services will be offered
between
uh non-traditional hours also
they will be a offer beyond the typical
four or five pm that we used to do at
other places
i i also want to share with you that
last week in grad county we
administered the 1 million dollars
for a resident here in grant county so
right now we can say that at least
one the more than one million
individuals in crowd county have
received at least
one dose of the kovi vaccine
the the grand total of vaccines
administered
by the the healthy street
uh our partners the pharmacist here in
grant county
is already over 1.7 million doses
i i also want to say that as we know
the cdc in recent dates updated the
guidelines and now
individuals who are fully vaccinated
can take advantage of that and you know
kind of
return to normal life or at least the
new normal if you wish
and that's the reason why right now i'm
not wearing
a mask with you because i i
am fully vaccinated with two doses
and uh and this is one of the the cdc
recommendations so
i just want to again to make sure
everybody
is aware of that i just want to say that
right now in crack county more than
56 57 of the population have
received at least one dose of vaccine
but
even sold our numbers
in terms of new cases reported every day
have decreased dramatically since
december we still are
in pandemic so as you know
today june 1st is actually
the the first day that
the the mass social distancing
recommendations are lifted in cloud
county and nevada
but still especially for those who are
not
vaccinated it's very important to to
consider that
and take advantage of the multiple
vaccination sites that are
here across the county and this
school actually would be one of those
places
i will stop here i will invite trustee
cepeda
please come home
thank you i'll be brief um
i think i speak for myself as well as
superintendent we are incredibly
thankful for this partnership
we know that our schools are beacons in
our community and they're places where
we know students
know they'll find a adult that cares
about them and we're really excited to
bring
vaccines the opportunity to get
vaccinated at one of our sites here
so we're very thankful for the
opportunity um
i will also take a minute to plug that
my 15 year old got his first vaccine
and he you know he's pretty excited to
get back to normal life so i think
let's do good for our neighbors by our
neighbors and let's all get vaccinated
it's really important to be able to get
back to
some normalcy but thank you very
thankful and with that i'll introduce
the superintendent
dr jesus harrah
thank you trustee cepeda and as dr
lagann mentioned we have been strong
partners with the southern nevada health
district from the beginning
of this pandemic that we've been dealing
with and estras dissipata mentioned
our public traditional schools are part
of the community are the beacons of our
community
from feeding our children our families
over 14 million meals
since this pandemic started 15 months
ago
in coordination and collaboration with
our great partners in the southern
nevada health district
and the county we were able to get to a
point that we were able to bring our
children back to school face to face in
march
we were able to end school last week
had a great ending we are finishing and
going through our graduation ceremonies
this last
week and to now and now as of today we
started our summer acceleration program
where our children are in school
hopefully to get back to a quick summer
and open schools next year and have a
successful year get back to the business
as i mentioned to dr lagann as he walked
in you know
as a great partnership we've had where
we're seeing the
light at the end of the tunnel but i
think again
as our school systems are part of this
community opening our doors to our
families
for vaccines i'm not wearing a mask
either because
i have been vaccinated on my two doses
as well so this is a welcome
for us and for our children and our
families a welcome partnership again
thank you
i do have to runs i've got to get to a
graduation
this evening
the desert pines partnership going
in southern nevada health district
uh
thank you very much
thank you
i mean that's a tough question too uh
forecasting is very difficult
i really cannot anticipate that what i
can tell you is that
because the cdc and the fda
when they approved a ficer vaccine for
20 years old and over they also review
their recommendation for physical
vaccine and now
they allowed or recommend that the
vaccine
can be offered simultaneously with other
vaccines
it makes easier for our immunization
system
or the pediatricians or family
practitioners
to offer this vaccine to children
in conjunction with vaccines that are
required by this
for the school system so is a great
great advantage because now
children who whose parents decide to
vaccinate them don't have to wait uh
14 days between the a kobe vaccine
and a different vaccine to be a minister
so but again
i i cannot forecast what would be
the number since this is something so
new
for everybody thank you
so the question is about the father who
are hesitant to
bring the children for vaccination and
yeah
well the vaccine has already been
demonstrated to be
safe in children as well as adults
actually as as you know the
the vaccine was approved for children
just a few weeks ago
and it was done only after a
studies weren't completed in in children
in the united states uh those studies
the
the main element for for those
was to be able to identify if
any uh adverse events severity
of the vaccine in children the studies
actually show that the vaccine
yes is highly effective in children as
well as in adults
and also that the the frequency the risk
of
uh averse or severe adverse events in
children
is is minimal and really when you look
at the the risk of
contracting coronavirus and
and the risk of adverse events is is
extremely
limited in children so that's why
the fda approved the vaccine
okay the question is whether the vaccine
will be mandatory for children
well i cannot anticipate that i
if that happened would be a decision of
starting at the federal level uh what i
can tell you right now
is that the vaseline is no mandatory
the vaccine is is being offered to
children
and and we actually require
the the approval or consent of the
parents for decision to be vaccinated
but
as far as i know here in nevada and
craig county at this point there is not
any discussion regarding a mandatory
vaccine for children
okay so the question is
if are we satisfied with the number for
children
being vaccinated so far well i i would
say that
we just started offering the vaccine
to children perhaps two weeks ago
and we we are looking at at the summer
and now when a parents start preparing
the children to go back to school that's
when typically
children are brought into the
immunization program for the child
so we are uh looking at taking advantage
of that
uh i would say tradition if you wish
in order to
to enhance our access to children and
being
able to offer the vaccine but again we
are just
starting offering the vaccine to
children
so we we had to look at the you know
the next few weeks to see what is the
progression of the campaign
in children so far
yeah i think i can speak as a parent
that you know we know the science behind
the vaccines
it is critical that we make sure our
students are protected our kids are
protected
um i mean they're just thinking to
history
all the different vaccines we've had in
the past uh you know polio
the first thing that comes to mind is
polio but you know there are measures
that are backed by science that are
important for our students to take
so that we can make sure that they're
safe and healthy so we could get back to
our normal living
my teen is he has a second dose
tomorrow the third so whatever the third
is because days just
fly by but you know he he's excited his
peers are excited to also be having the
vaccine so he has plenty of friends who
have taken that first shot
and again i think everyone's just kind
of really
looking forward to being normal
walking around without a mask uh not
having to be physically distant
obviously we still want our students to
be socially
connected but you know just physically
distant so i
i guess i could speak as a parent in
that in that regard where
he's excited we're excited and that we
want to be good citizens we want to be
good citizens and big be good neighbors
to our partners to our family our
friends our neighbors
our community so and to do that we need
you know we need to be mindful about
others as well
as well as ourselves
for next school year for this well i'm
not too sure yet
i'll definitely refer to the
superintendent i know
him and his team are talking about it
making sure that we make the decision
that again aligns the most with science
and the guidelines placed forth by the
state and federal government so
stay tuned
yeah i i will look i will look to our
communications team because they're
phenomenal
they're putting on putting it out on
social media i'm sure there's
a parent link
and word of mouth we know that there is
um
there's power and organic movements
right so we definitely want folks to
hopefully be able to
you know share it on there on their
socials and
and be able to be part of you know part
of the movement
to get everyone everyone vaccinated so
hi
what was the question um
you know i graduated high school in
2007. in 2007 our budget was like four
billion dollars
it is currently like two two point
something
billion um so that's a bit of
to me it's it's dramatic it's you know
over 13 13 years ago and
and we see those fruits now
every con every year we consistently cut
and so honestly
i am just very thankful very thankful
that our state leaders are able to
you know bring additional revenue
revenue to our schools because it's
critical it's how we get
more people because again we're a people
organization
70 plus percent of our budget goes to
people
so it's it's essential like please
more yeah that's all i will say thank
you and just please more